dit pas son nom
quand pour un monde
montant total ligne
[Musique]
avant compteur le dessus sur les harraga
bon on s'envole avec l'épître où c'est
parti
[Musique]
on a quatre parties d'activité une
activité que les pilotes déjà
expérimentés viennent pour faire des
vols avec les treuils activité très
associative où tout le monde fuit les
incombant pour rouler ensuite en
activité et coll développé depuis 4 5
ans j'ai passé mon tour à fédéral et du
coup l'activité collecte permet
d'apprendre à faire du parapente que si
tu es à petit avec des journées de
formation un peu de théorie de la
pratique on a une activité de bi place
donc pour les gens qui veulent découvrir
le prendre en compte
et qui peut juste avoir une expérience
d'un quart d'heure
suite à un troisième la quatrième
activité ses activités autour du
handicap
[Musique]
qu'il faut savoir c'est que le parapente
est tout à fait accessible à des
personnes qui sont handicapés il ya deux
possibilités sert de faire un baptême de
l'air comme on dit un de voler en
biplace où la personne handicapée est
seulement passagère et elle va être dans
un fauteuil de vol spécial avec des
notes derrière qui sont quand une
qualification vers l'est en fauteuil de
personnes handicapées et puis c'est
également accessibles donc comme pilote
j'ai eu un accident tous présents j'ai
revu les trois ans après et pour moi
c'était un énorme plaisir
c'était vraiment dire une victoire sur
la vie de reprendre goût à la vie
n'importe qui et avec une autorisation
quand même médical peut apprendre à
voler et c'est tout à fait accessible
vraiment
[Musique]
vite
vite en
fait un sonar cours donc un camp d'été
les gens du club vient de s'installer
dans deux semaines les adhérentes les
gens des pilotes qui viennent d'ailleurs
conviennent aux sites de trois jours une
semaine pour les enfants et si on
propose des baptêmes de l'air en biplace
c2 présent les deux premières car il a
les deux premières secondes on se fait
plaisir les gens sont heureux de
méfiance a recommandé
[Musique]